Chris Haynes of Yahoo Sports senior NBA
insider has been all over this story
with the the draymond Green suspension
in Golden State he's back here on the
show how you doing Chris oh please I
love your work I love our chats Chris so
congrats on the Yahoo gig by the way I
know we haven't spoken since that so
have you spoken to dream on did you
speak to him yeah he just he just spoke
to the to the press Kalam here in
Houston he essentially
gave a statement it was probably about a
children 3 3 minute statement on the KD
situation he didn't dive too much into
it but he gave that he didn't he didn't
take questions out so can you paraphrase
what he had to say then Chris at times
he left he allows us the motion to get
the best of them but he said he's not
gonna change that because more times out
of not you know that's exactly what the
team needs at times that's how he drives
and he basically said people that was
trying to write the narrative this is
gonna be the Warriors kind of this is
gonna be the Warriors you know kind of
end of their dynasties say I'm sorry to
disrupt that but that that's not going
to be the case you say him and Kevin
spoke believe they spoke this morning
and uh you know he said they're good
they're moving forth and so that was
kind of his message to everybody that
this is not going to this is not what's
going to be what's going on the rail
deal from trying to attempt uh their
third consecutive championship that and
he said for those who with who think
that this was the Vail hit the air he
said that's not the case okay so he's
accepting responsibility for whatever
happened in between apologized he didn't
apologize III didn't catch an apology in
that time and he didn't say that he
apologized to Kevin Durant as well I
don't know if that you know I don't know
if that took place is not but I didn't
kiss that in his treatment of statement
well you know just to refer for all due
respect to some of our
viewers and listeners earmuffs your
headline of sources dream on green
suspended after calling Kevin Durant a
[ __ ] is a very rare headline to see so
can you put any more information around
all that as to what did in fact happen
in that huddle in between regulation and
overtime in Los Angeles this week yeah
well basically it got to us what we all
know that you know great mom before that
hello draymond gravity the office
rebound and proceeded to drive up court
it's almost like he ignored Kevin Durant
you know pounding for the ball clapping
for the ball then they got some
situation when I got to the huddle
you know Durant called them out about
that and uh I think three mob was just a
little bit embarrassed and taken back at
that time you know Trayvon you you at
times you'll see draymond talking that
way or getting on players that way but
it's rare you see players getting on him
about that and I think he was just
caught in a situation that he's not
accustomed to and he went off you know
and it got personal and I think if you
look at the huddle you will see the ran
his face kind of changed like whoa he's
going there he went you know he went
personal with the with the B references
and talked about you know talking about
free agency situation about you know
that's that's holding things up and you
know they just took it to a place where
it wasn't supposed to be when you're in
the heat of heat of a battle competition
so Minoo this was you know I know people
talk about you know those those who have
desktop for but obviously this is
something different that organization
felt they had to jump in it and and
apply discipline so you know Dre claims
that this is you know this is their
moved on past it he said he's not going
to change and so it'll be interesting to
see how this unfolds but particularly
when we do get to free agency in the
summer well I mean him Chris Haynes of
Yahoo Sports here in the Rich Eisen show
dream on just the way I'm looking at it
draymond not changing is a good thing
for the Warriors because when he has
that sort of persona attitude in an
outward direction it is an absolute
benefit to the Golden State Warriors I
mean there's no question about that
but when he trains
in word that is the issue and even if he
does say that I realize that folks are
saying this is the only way the Warriors
can be beaten is if we implode from
within and I'm not gonna be that cause
that's fine but Kevin Durant's not
making a free agency decision between
now and June so that's always going to
be lingering isn't it Chris no it is and
you know that the sad part about the
situation if you are go to stay for span
or if you remember this organization is
that if Kevin Durant does indeed leave
everybody is going to point to that
incident they're going to point to that
that that will be the narrative of dream
on being the sole reason why Kevin
Durant bolted we're all going to point
to that we talked about the Bulls all
you know we blame people for for their
role and not keeping that team together
and talking about how many temperatures
they could have it would be the same
situation here and go to state if the
even if they do win three titles they
win three titles and a little KD bolts
they're gonna point to this situation
and say is this the cause of why this
team broke up just the reason why Katie
left and so it's a crucial situation you
know we truly won't know the true reason
why Katie left if that is the case but
there's no doubt about it people are
gonna point to that when this would
happen if Steph wasn't hurt Chris uh if
he wasn't her I don't think the game
would be that close for it to happen
like that and obviously if it was that
close Steph would be the one dribbling
the ball up the court potentially as
opposed to dream on but I guess what I'm
bringing up here is that it might not
have happened on Monday night but this
is something lingering isn't it I mean
everyone involved might say that the
goal the free agency is not an issue but
it sure appears to be in the fact that
drayman's got only one year left as well
he might be wondering about his future
there that can be the case and I think
that's why you know those states felt
like they had to step in it and you know
implement this implement this decision
and you know it just it went outside of
basketball you know you can both both
both parties were at fault to some
extent but I think
kaydee he went at three ma you could say
it was longer right but he went at dream
on it was purely there solely about
basketball why he's been passing the
ball give me the ball you know he might
you know crust an heir or whatever
dream on took it outside the basketball
with coastal went business that that's
never supposed to be integrated into the
line of competition I've completely out
about and is that why it seems that
management sided with Durant or do you
think that any of that has to do with
free agency that say hey we've got your
back remember that come July 1 now look
go to state they're not gonna come out
and say this has anything to do with
creating their point in you know they
said that their point is that implement
this was that he crossed the line and
they wouldn't get into specifics about
what it what he actually did crossed
that line but come on now it's not easy
to connect the dots you know okay KD is
gonna be a free agent over the summer
you declined that player option they
want to keep them and four or something
like that to happen especially with the
guy who recruited him in the first place
you know they thought they had to take
take action and this is a pretty big
game for the Rockets tonight too
you're gonna be about the latest one I'm
asked this week Chris I still haven't
gotten an answer
Dwyane Wade's tweet this week saying
that Carmelo Anthony is the fall guy in
Houston saying that we're not talking
about the real stuff in a way who is he
referring to nobody's been able to
determine that do you have a best guess
or an any knowledge on this not not
extensively on me look I think a lot of
it is just that you know the talent that
they let go over the offseason they were
never able to replace that I'm talking
about Trevor Ariza who is oddly one and
most important pieces last year somebody
who 3d player guards the best for him to
play on the chain and doesn't get a lot
of credit for it and let him go and they
let loose a go and so those are key
those are key pieces to that team and
that puzzle they kind of lost their D
sense of identity in let them go so
there's a bunch of difference you know
a bunch of different other factors that
can be in the play but to me when you
talk about the demise this team does far
I got to point out the the offseason
moves that they didn't make that's the
reason why carmella did play enough
games he has to play enough mana to put
it all on him but it's definitely
looking like well organization is kind
of put them in escapes which was so
Dwayne Wade is is referring to the front
office in that tweet uh to do wait okay
I can only go off of what you know what
I see alright last question for you
asked retains the poll question from
yesterday Chris Brockman if you remember
that before we go out the door here yeah
yeah Chris what's the most likely
scenario for the Warriors next season
Durant gone dream on gone via trade both
back both gone I think the first one the
first one is KD gone another one is both
gone both stay or it's just draymond on
but as a right now I would be for Katy
probably be going device there all right
and you think that's the Knicks I think
they'll be up they'll be in a mix along
with both la chaîne okay Chris thanks
for the call appreciate it
oh I will take care of my god you got it
right back at that Chris Haynes of Yahoo
Sports
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience